Only these two graph parabolas. Which might surprise you. In particular, this
equation, y equals x squared plus 2 xy plus 1 does not graph a parabola. Even
though there is a x squared term, there's also this term 2 xy. Looking back at
the general form, we don't see any terms here that have both x and y in them
multiplied together, so this does not fit the bill. We'll see this graph in just
a second. And, of course, you'll recognize this graph as a straight line. This
is linear. Think to yourself what the slope is and what the y-coordinate or the
y-intercept is. This last answer may also have been a little bit tricky for you.
I know that right now this doesn't look at all, like this general form equation
of a parabola. But if we distributed multiplication by what's in this first set
of parenthesis towards on the second one, we get something pretty interesting.
In fact, let's look at the graphs for all four of these right now. So here are
the graphs for all 4 of the equations we just looked at. This funny red curve,
which has a big break in the middle, is the graph that corresponds to the
equation that we've never seen anything like before. Y equals x squared plus 2
xy plus 1. How funny that this isn't even in one piece. This is called a
hyperbola. We're not really going to deal with them much. But it's important to
recognize that having a term like xy makes an equation no longer equation of a
parabola. This solitary straight line is of course y equals 5 x plus 7. The
yellow curve, is the parabola y equals 3 x squared plus 2 x. And this last curve
left, this big blue arc, is y equals negative 1 8th, x minus 4, times x minus
24. Because if you multiplied out all of the terms inside here, we'd end up with
a term with an x squared in it, as the only term of degree 2. And it does,
indeed, graph a parabola.